i really
really thought we were done apparently
we weren't because there's one
more world champion to consider
after anand and that is unfortunately
yours truly in terms of genius though
i think i don't consider myself
a genius in general i think uh in chess
terms
i should score fairly highly because
i'm i think i believe uh
quite naturally talented so i'm going to
give an eight here
in terms of being entertaining obviously
i'm an
extremely entertaining person like uh
my my jokes are drier than wood and
i have some things going for me i think
in terms of entertaining on the
chessboard in that
i'm open to trying new ideas i'm always
fighting towards the very end but i also
understand that my style
[Music]
is still slightly geared towards longer
games
and it's not everybody's cup of tea but
i think still
an eight is pretty pretty fair here
i'm probably more on the unknown side
here of not necessarily coming up with
the
ideas myself and being more of a
follower than
than a creator there has obviously been
a chess chest bit of a chess boom in in
norway so that
that helps but i think uh influence
is not my my greatest strengths so i'm
i'm gonna go with the seven here
in terms of sanity
you know i have my moments good and bad
overall i think it's
[Music]
i'm somebody who can certainly be very
upset
after games usually it doesn't doesn't
last
and um there haven't been
uh any uh two egregious moments so far
uh so i'm gonna give myself the highest
the highest grade that i get on any of
these will be on sanity and it's going
to be
a very subjective night
you